in our series a more perfect union we
aim to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us this morning Jan Crawford
shows us the healing power of
fly-fishing
she went to Oregon and pulled on a pair
of waders to see how one man is
inspiring others with free outdoor
adventures good morning Jan well good
morning John so this man Chad brown I
mean he says he was really at his lowest
point when he found fly-fishing so now
he's bringing different groups of kids
and veterans to join him on the river
and they are casting their rods in Utah
Florida the Arctic Circle and across the
Pacific Northwest it's a bright sunny
day on the Crooked River in Central
Oregon just around a bend kids are
angling for trout but what's happening
in this river runs much deeper than
catching a fish there's no guarantee I'm
coming back here with family Janette
Garcia is a self-described city kid with
people it's kind of rough sometimes but
you know it was a time to relax and just
find yourself
that's what Chad Brown was hoping for
when he started Sol River the Portland
based nonprofit offers an escape into
nature for veterans and kids who might
not otherwise have the opportunity it's
a coping mechanism for me it erases
everything around me and allows me to
focus on what's exactly in front of me
right at that moment basically I'm it
may not have anything to do to get into
fish basically you know but I think oh
I'm hooked
I got fished Brown is a navy veteran he
served in the Gulf and patrolled the
dangerous streets of Mogadishu Somalia
he returned home broken desperate to
escape the anxiety blackouts and
nightmares brought on by PTSD it all
came crashing down to one place and it
stripped me from everything I lost
completely everything I became homeless
I was homeless in the streets in
Portland Oregon oh it's the lowest point
finding myself in the blood lines
sitting there pumping and trying to feel
a pint of blood so I can get $20 I've
never thought in my life that I was
going to find myself in a place like
that and in and I was embarrassed he
started treatment at the VA for PTSD he
got a service dog named axe but it
wasn't until a friend took him fishing
that he found his real medicine I was
like a walking zombie with that much
medication and assistance I couldn't
smile when you cooked that fish what did
that feel like it's that jolt of energy
of life that brought me into the present
where I can actually be able to feel the
air feel the currents that I'm standing
in the water
it made me alive Brown says his doctors
actually prescribed nature and
fly-fishing a different kind of healing
he's passing along through soul river
there are veterans out there that are
fighting their stuff there are also
young people out there fighting their
stuff as well they're walking around
with like duct tape over their mouths
basically right is trapped right if I
couldn't bring these worlds together
where that veteran serves that you and
that you serves that veteran they're
both having the the wounded souls here
fly-fishing is my salvation I come out
here this is my church my happy place
after leaving the Marine Corps Daniel
Wynn was looking for another opportunity
to serve what soul river provides to me
are these short perfect moments having
the opportunity to teach a youth
fly-fishing and then watch them catch
fish and what's that way
it's uh met its this ear to ear you
smile feeling because on these trips
kids also learn about the environment
conservation and leadership just this
dependability initiative decisiveness
I love the vets they're like extremely
amazing mentor tried to pull some pieces
out of what Dan is saying and apply to
your personal life dad you know he went
through a lot of rough times and he's
here now and he's a leader and I really
admire him for that and when you say
it's inspiring I mean what's the message
from that that you can do what you want
if you dream about it and if you aspire
to be that person you can do that break
it up in teams everybody down to waiters
rides for Brown has found his purpose
and hopes he's hooked a new generation
of leaders we all have our issues we
find different things in life and what
are we going up against the river has a
way of listening giving us that space if
it weren't for this some of these kids
might go a different direction might go
different direction you know and then on
top of that these kids know that these
veterans have their back now both the
kids and the veterans say there's a lot
of new skills to learn on these trips
but they also learn about themselves I
mean they're becoming more like
self-aware and patient open and really
appreciative of opportunities Nora
Wow Jim thank you so much to you and
producer Kara Cleveland for bringing us
that story and some reminder of why our
show is so great you know that we do
these sorts of stories and so different
about how people are helping one another
helping others who've gone through
adversity and challenges and have
changed things like the line he said
fly-fishing is my salvation that's a
pretty great endorsement yeah yeah and
though when you're talking about those
short perfect moments you could feel the
short perfect moments and hear it in the
water and I'm that was a good way I want
to go to or yeah